uh we got a call from a viewer last week
who brought up china
and a discussion of the portrayal of
china in american media
and during that conversation during that
phone call we talked about xenophobia
towards asian americans over covid we
talked about intellectual property theft
and a few other topics and i got a very
good email from thomas over the weekend
and thomas said to me you know david
um there is a china story to talk about
but it's not really what the caller
brought up intellectual property theft
it's an issue it's not the major
geopolitical issue with china
there's no real evidence that china
intentionally released covet as a bio
weapon so that's not really like the big
story with china yes xenophobia against
asian americans for real or perceived
misdeeds by china is something we should
be against we're not going to be
xenophobic against asian americans
because of something the chinese
government did that that's happening and
that's bad
but thomas wrote there are real issues
with the chinese communist party now
that's another issue to clarify
the ccp and china
as in chinese people are two different
things we're really talking about the
chinese government the chinese communist
party and as thomas wrote to me
there's a ton of negativity towards
china in general that's very surface
level some of it is based in plain old
bigotry some of it is peddled by u.s
media but there are many real reasons to
be at odds with the actions of the
chinese communist party so let's look at
the real concerns with the chinese
government the ccp
and these are not reasons to go to war
with china caveat i'm not suggesting war
i know that there's people possibly on
the revolutionary left who will see this
segment and say i'm calling for another
american military intervention no the
i'm not even saying these are reasons to
no longer trade with china if we stop
trading with china would be disastrous
for the american economy as it's
currently set up we're just going to
talk about issues with the chinese
government first
the ongoing uyghur genocide uyghurs are
a muslim ethnic minority in china china
has been credibly accused of committing
crimes against humanity possibly
genocide against the uyghur population
and other mostly muslim ethnic groups in
the northwest region of xinjiang
leading human rights groups including
amnesty and human rights watch have put
out reports accusing china
of crimes against humanity for their
actions there are re-education camps
there are horrifying things and much has
been written about it that's a real
substantive issue
with the chinese government second organ
harvesting this is all
the if you put a positive spin on it
this is oh
we get organ donations from prisoners
who have died of natural causes that's
the story that china would tell
but a tribunal ruled in 2020 that china
is forcibly harvesting organs from
prisoners prisoners who certainly didn't
volunteer to donate organs but it goes
even further possibly even prisoners who
are killed for organs not who have died
naturally
the number of transplant centers in
china has gone up over 300 percent wait
times for organs have come down
dramatically it's not clear why china
doesn't have much in terms of an
organized organ donation program how is
it happens how has it happened it seems
this is a likely explanation and it is
absolutely horrifying
note that back in 2012
a top chinese official said china is
going to phase out the practice of
taking organs from prisoners who have
been executed as of 2020 we believe that
that's still going on even if it's not
aside from executed there's a lot of
other ways that you can accelerate the
process of obtaining organs from
prisoners it seems that that's being
done absolutely horrifying number three
china so poorly mismanages its own
infrastructure
that it likely has led to hundreds or
more chinese people it's hard to get
real numbers from the ccp to die
due to flooding and the idea here is
that yes there have been heavy
rainstorms that are not man-made right
humans didn't make the rainstorms but
there are serious allegations that the
deaths are a result of this
infrastructure madness craze in china
where money is poured into projects that
look good
sometimes generate returns for people
but meanwhile simple infrastructure that
could be improved to prevent senseless
death from heavy rains and people
drowning are ignored okay complete
mismanagement that's a real criticism of
what's being done and then such
corruption from the ccp that causes all
sorts of problems massive fraud
embezzlement around these half-finished
villages where people make a ton of
money the projects are abandoned after
the contracts and the cash are handed
out as well as reconstruction projects
that never really happen although many
people get rich from them and then
lastly and this is a really big deal
a china's continued aggressive posturing
towards india taiwan and the south and
east china seas more generally each of
which we've talked about a little bit in
the past so on india there have been
somewhere between four and ten
skirmishes of note between india and
china over the border various face-offs
we've talked about it a little bit on
the bonus show before
the situation in the south china sea
involving china the philippines and
vietnam where you see military activity
by china naval maneuvers other
aggression outposts being built
concerning and then also conflicts with
japan and the east china sea um other
part of the sea it include uh it
includes japan having scrambled jets in
the past and other uh escalations so to
be clear again i want to be really
careful
i don't want war with china i'm not
saying invade china i'm not saying the
u.s doesn't also do bad things lots of
countries exhibit this type of
aggression
the difference is number one a lot of
the criticisms of china in the u.s media
and from you know people like trump have
been very surface level and lead to
xenophobia against asian americans which
has no place whatsoever there are actual
horrible things being done by the
chinese government many countries that
also want to do horrible things don't
have both the aggression and the the
means to carry it out the financial
resources at their disposal the massive
population that china has bigotry
against asian americans because of this
or chinese people anywhere is wrong and
we're against it
i'm also not saying cut off china from
an economic standpoint our economy is
now too inter intertwined with china's
it would take a really long time to be
able to unentangle that relationship
without destroying the american economy
so i'm not calling for that but there
are real geopolitical issues here and
humanitarian issues about which we
should be concerned it's not bigotry to
talk about that and the american media
rarely touches these actual issues
let me know what you think we'll have
more on this story on the david pakman
show instagram which you can find at
david pakman's show on instagram